♪ (GRANDIOSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
(HONKING)
The whole government
is compromised.
They made it seem
like our votes counted,
but our votes wasn't worth
a lit fart in a wool mitten.
(YELPS)
This seems like a good way
to start the movie.
♪ (SERIOUS MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
My name's Andrew Callaghan,
and I first went viral online
for interviewing people
on the road,
going to different conventions,
conspiracy rallies,
music festivals.
Then in 2020,
shit got super serious.
-Protests...
-Police brutality.
That shit is real!
It's revolution time.
ANDREW CALLAGHAN:
...pandemics...
-(GROANS)
-Remember that?
Freedom!
CALLAGHAN: So, this is the story
of the events that led up
to the January 6 Capitol riot...
-RIOTER: We are the storm!
-(CHEERING)
...as I saw them unfold.
♪ (WHIMSICAL MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
REPORTER: You may have gone
to bed thinking this election
was headed one way...
Donald Trump!
REPORTER:
...and then you woke up
and saw things were different
and trending increasingly
in another direction.
Woo!
We saved the country!
REPORTER:
Joe Biden is the apparent winner
in the state of Wisconsin.
No more mail-in ballots,
Mr. Mailbox!
So while it was true that
everyday people on the right
were being censored
and kicked off social media...
Ninety-eight percent
of the media
have a leftist agenda
to bring in communism
and a one-world government.
It only just pushed them
to alt platforms...
SPEAKER: This is the sign
for a boy-lover.
... and into tighter
and tighter echo chambers.
They've been sacrificing
children to Moloch.
ALEX JONES:
Animal human clones.
I want to start a commune.
If you need anything,
you get it. There is no money.
-SPEAKER 2: Whose streets?
-PROUD BOYS: Our streets!
-Whose streets?
PROTESTORS: No Trump!
No KKK, no fascist USA!
CALLAGHAN: We were pitted
against each other
by organizations and individuals
who do not care about us
and are enriched
from our division.
JONES:
You are the tip of the spear!
Do you ever feel
like you've gone too far
down the rabbit hole, man?
ELDERLY PROTESTOR:
This is only the beginning.
What's the end?
There is no end!
(LAUGHS)
-(ELEPHANT TRUMPETS)
-(DONKEY BRAYS)